[Música]
se trata de un destino de vocaciones que
los franceses aprueban el camping
archell en los pirineos orientales es la
ciudad de Europa donde se encuentran más
terrenos en verano en este pequeño
Rincón del Mediterráneo la cantidad de
habitantes es multiplicada por 10
aquí nació gijón sus abuelos fundaron
este camping su madre lo retomó
ahora es su turno de retomar el negocio
es el tipo de cosas que veo no dejo en
la zona de juegos de niños una botella
de cerveza hace 10 años que es director
y revisa sus 10 hectáreas con minucia
estamos donde nosotros es nuestro
terreno nuestra historia nacimos aquí
hace parte de nuestra vida al 100% el
día de mañana si eres director de un
lugar o acabas de llegar o estás aquí
tres años no es la misma dedicación
esta temporada turística es para él un
poco especial porque trabaja desde hace
algunos meses con un nuevo codirector su
hermano mayor Frank era banquero de
inversión en París no se arrepiente de
su elección
para mí trabajar aquí tiene como un
suplemento de Alma
es un poco particular quiero decir que
los árboles que están aquí alrededor de
nosotros
Fueron sembrados por mis abuelos crecía
aquí mi madre también
Y actualmente Cuando veo a mis hijos que
hacen una siesta al lado en un carro
casa Me da gusto durante la temporada de
verano los dos hermanos cuentan con una
veintena de empleados para darle vida al
camping
entre ellos los animadores hoy
seleccionan los trajes para el
espectáculo
la dificultad en este tipo de ejercicios
es que hay muchas tallas diferentes
entonces va desde el camarón hasta el
bogavante doble pinza Y entonces hay que
vestir a todo el mundo
profesional administraba un cabaret hoy
se produce en el camping falleció
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el espectáculo tiene lugar mañana para
los turistas será el evento final de su
semana en el camping
veladas de espectáculos a él con sus 53
campings ha vivido miles fue en los años
30 que las carpas empezaron a colonizar
el Pinar la playa y los campos de los
alrededores un agricultor junto al señor
boaj se dice que Pudo sacar un beneficio
extrayendo una regalía así nació el
primer camping privado de argel en 1953
los decenios siguientes marcarán la edad
de oro del camping
desde aquella época viene el camping de
los hermanos Frank y Ramón en 1964 sus
abuelos agricultores deciden arrancar la
viña y plantar pinos para acoger a los
campistas luego su madre Anahí toma el
relevo en 1979 es ella quien instala los
primeros carrozas y fideliza así a los
clientes a los que ve desde hace 25 años
con el mismo gusto
es lo más especial del asunto
casa en el camping es eso
porque vemos a todo el mundo lo
importante que es para ellos su lugar de
vacaciones
es ameno no es una gran fábrica como
otros cambios
esta noche todos los hay se reúnen para
un aperitivo en familia la oportunidad
de sacar los archivos y reírse todos
juntos sobre el tiempo que transcurre
esto
tres generaciones han hecho de este
camping un éxito y el relevo está casi
garantizado
creo que hay un orgullo de tratar de
entregarle el relevo a la cuarta
generación
no parecen tan Bondadosos los unos con
los otros
Artur Gabriel
para los animadores es la gran noche los
primeros visitantes de la temporada
están aquí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tras bastidores el temor aumenta para
Fred
estamos un poco apurados tenemos tan
solo una canción para cambiarnos pero lo
lograremos estar listo es un verdadero
trabajo en equipo está claro nos
apoyamos en este caso los cordones
[Música]
maravilloso francamente maravilloso
nunca habíamos visto uno tan hermoso y
hemos visitado cambios Es agradable
pasamos buenos momentos y estamos muy
contentos nosotros estamos aquí por
primera vez
una velada exitosa y un buen test para
los propietarios del campo muy bien para
un espectáculo de inicio de temporada es
perfecto si no tuviésemos esta música
este ambiente el camping sería apagado
todo estaría muerto evidente se
aburriría un poco entonces hace parte
del ambiente general del camping
los franceses y el camping una historia
de amor que perdura cada año son más de
6 millones los que optan por esta forma
de vacaciones amigable